the art of performing magic is really
the art of managing attention stop here
yeah look at the car three two three
three yes three doesn't matter a general
rule of thumb is that when a magician
says that something doesn't matter the
opposite is usually true for example a
couple of minutes ago
when David Blaine slipped three more
cards into what everyone else thinks is
a pile of ten then asked to read to put
them over his heart the only thing that
matters is that Jimmy Fallon chooses the
number three from this forced flourish
so that when Blaine says that three
cards will magically fly from his deck
into Tariq's hand the thirteen cards
will be there and everyone will freak
out ten ten zeros on the eleven Wow did
you catch it that time
ten ten zeros on number eleven there's
three and there's four more now there's
20 cards this is a great trick from
David Blaine and it functions on a
simple concept which all magic depends
on selective attention the idea that the
eyes and the mind can only focus on one
thing at a time this principle is
something that magicians have known for
centuries in the earliest known book of
magic and English hocus pocus the author
includes in his for required skills for
magic tricks such gestures of body as
may lead the spectators eyes from a
strict and diligent beholding of his
manner of conveyance a few hundred years
later scientists began conducting tests
on selective attention like this one
from Declan Servan from 1983 which asks
subjects to count the number of times
the white-shirted players passed the
ball back and forth in this end other
tests like it a majority of people more
than half failed to see the woman with
the Umbrella walking directly through
the middle of the scene the important
thing to note is that selective
attention is something that organizes
our entire experience as human beings
not just our vision I mean David Blaine
may be distracting Jimmy Fallon and the
roots when he loads these extra cards
into the pile but what's more amazing
than the sleight of hand is that he's
doing it in exactly the place for
everyone is looking and this shows just
how powerful selective attention can be
in magic manipulating attention is fun
it's what we expect but it's not the
only place we find this kind of activity
let's take a look at another trick are
you watching closely on Sunday November
27th the New York Times published a
comprehensive piece of good journalism
detailing country by country the empire
of business interests that Donald Trump
has around the globe and how they might
conflict with his job as president the
story was at the top of the front page
then at around 12:30 that afternoon
Trump tweeted this in addition to
winning the electoral college in a
landslide I won the popular vote if you
deduct the millions of people who voted
illegally make no mistake this is a kind
of magic trick like David Blaine like
any magician Donald Trump is using
selective attention for his own game
he's misdirecting sucking all the air
out of a story that he wants you to
forget misdirection is not new to
politics politicians have been
manipulating our attention for years I
mean when the public asks a question
politicians figured out long ago that
rather than actually answer it it's much
much better to change the question when
you address negative publicity on its
own terms you end up with stuff like
this people have got to know whether or
not their presidents a crook well I'm
not a crook I've earned everything I've
got instead of moving attention away
from the question of his criminality
Nixon aimed the focus directly on to
that issue by denying it outright a
better magic trick is something that
happened a few years earlier when
Vietnam War protests were gripping the
country in the 1960s politicians and
elites who supported the war didn't
address the protesters actual concerns
about the legitimacy of the conflict
instead they reframed the anti-war
protests as anti troop protests and this
political sleight of hand has proven
really fruitful and undercutting
protesters not just the Vietnam War but
of the Gulf War and the wars on terror
that followed I asked
American define away to thank the men
and women were defending our freedom now
Donald Trump takes this a step further
he uses Twitter to maneuver attention
away from negative press but he doesn't
reframe the debate so much as distract
the country with statements so glaringly
false and controversial but the media is
forced to expend its energy on refuting
them or covering them because they have
to because the winning president elects
saying without evidence that millions of
people voted illegally will get ratings
because when the president makes a farce
of the presidency that is in some sad
way newsworthy and then when you're done
covering that a new tweet comes in that
says flag burner should perhaps lose
their citizenship or be sent to jail for
a year I mean it's really amazing the
attention goes where he wants it to go
and without the pressure of sustained
focus the chairman of the House
Oversight Committee is free to brush the
real issue the one we all forgot about
aside I think you can expect this kind
of thing to the next four years expect
every substantive criticism to be met
with a ridiculous tweet it's time for
all of us to start thinking of our own
attention as a limited and valuable
resource because when you do you can be
a little more certain that the card
you're choosing is actually yours
stop
there is a new nerdwriter video every
Wednesday guys so if you click that box
that I've conveniently set up right
there you'll subscribe to this channel
and get all the videos sorry David
Blaine for revealing how your trick is
done but it was a useful metaphor for
what I want to talk about thank you to
Squarespace for sponsoring this video
they make a sleek intuitive websites
where you can go and make a website
without having to know coding I made one
called the nerdwriter net which you can
check out and save sort of an example if
you sign up for a year you can get a
free domain name and if you use the
offer code nerdwriter you get 10% off
your first purchase thank you for
helping to fund this channel without
asking to interfere in the content
that's a huge thing for me as a lot of
you guys know anyway I'll see the rest
of you next Wednesday